[Music]
these paintings are among the oldest in
the world a window into the minds of our
ancestors they were found decades ago in
caves in Indonesia but recently
scientists have managed to date them the
paintings are much older than anybody
expected causing scientists to rethink
the history of early human creativity
here we are and this is a very important
rocker panel to understand human
evolution on the right here we have a
hen stencil and the minimum age for that
hand stencil is thirty nine point nine
thousand years and this is the oldest n
stencil in the world and on the left
here we are the fiction of a Barbarossa
big BM and the minimum age for that
painting is thirty five point four
thousand years ago that makes it the
oldest figurative depiction in the world
okay it's a very nice detailed painting
we can see either the little legs a tail
the hair I think maybe at the back of
the neck and doors and it wasn't really
rare today they're almost extinct
finding animals and hand stencils
created so long ago in Asia is a real
surprise because until now the focus has
been on Europe on charcoal paintings
like these from the Chauvet Cave in
France and on small sculptures found in
caves in Germany so we have
representational art in Europe from at
least 35,000 years ago and I have a
couple of examples here not put onto the
walls of caves but sculpted examples so
these are replicas of little statuettes
of animals made from mammoth ivory here
we have a representation of a horse and
a mammoth and these were found in German
caves and the remains are dated 35 to 40
thousand years ago and there's been a
view that there was a sort of creative
Explorer
illusion when modern humans arrived in
Europe that triggered this tremendous
creativity that we find in the cave art
and that view really also suggested that
the aren't we found in other parts of
the world came later and developed
independently in those different regions
but the new work suggests that our
ancestors were painting in Europe and
Asia at the same time creating murals
that may have covered the ceilings and
walls of their caves unfortunately only
remnants of their artworks remained
sometimes we can see beautiful hand
stencil but most of the paintings are
gone
and I think like maybe not 99% of all of
the paintings are all gone and what we
can see today is only the remnant of the
Thomas was fully painted panel upon one
in the early 1980s
there are a lot of cave paintings on
this site in the form of hand stencils
as you can see now a lot has been
damaged through exfoliation pieces
falling off and others are covered by
calcium carbonate the calcium carbonate
deposits which contain radioactive
uranium gave the team a way of dating
the paintings unable to date the paint
layer itself but here on top of the
painting we have the cave popcorn and
their cat some carbonate Larry
nice more layers it's like a stalactite
or a start like an earth in there in a
cave at a very micro scale and these are
forming on top of the painting but
sometimes also you have layers under the
painting is open so if we can get a
sample on top of the paint layer but
then it becomes a minimum age for the
painting and if we can date the layer
under the painting then we have a
maximum age if the new dates are right
and the Indonesian cave art is at least
as old if not older than the paintings
in Europe then art didn't emerge first
in Europe instead it's likely that the
ancestors of Europeans and Asian's were
artists so I think this suggests that
modern humans have this creativity this
artistic expression with them when they
spread out of Africa and of course this
art was ultimately taken right across
Asia down into Southeast Asia eventually
into Australia and New Guinea and I
think that some of the art in Australia
will also eventually be dated to this
very early time